We Begin north of Tel Aviv where at
least 18 Israelis have been injured and
one killed in ramming and stabbing
incidents Israeli police say two
suspects were arrested in connection to
the attack an investigation is underway
the public has been urged to remain
Vigilant we have cor two correspondents
following this breaking story for us in
a moment we'll go to nid ibraim in
ramala but first let's go straight to S
who is in Tel Aviv for us so s what more
do we know at this point about these
attacks
well the police now say they have the
situation under control what we do know
is that one person has died from their
wounds an elderly lady as well as 18
others critically injured including uh
children now this happened in an area
called ranana which is north of where we
are here in uh Tel Aviv it was an
ongoing uh situation where there are now
two two suspects that have been arrested
but for a long time uh the police had uh
deployed all of their units they said
they had helicopters hovering in the sky
as one of them was on the Run they were
trying uh to look for him there was a
lot of confusion as to what happened and
the reason why there was confusion is
that it seems uh both of them were
working in a car uh uh cleaning uh
business and they had actually taken
over one of the cars they then rammed a
few people switched cars to another car
where an elderly lady was taken out of
the car that was the one that has died
from her wounds and then rammed into
more people at the time also uh they had
advised all of the schools to uh keep
the children inside one of the attacks
happened near a school just outside of
the gates uh and then also earlier we
also heard from the former prime
minister Natalie Bennett that lives in
that era he was stopped from being able
to get get to his home because they've
closed off that area for further
investigation now he did speak to local
media and he said this is just proof
that we are under attack from all sides
from the north as well as the South and
he said even from um the West Bank he
said and he said that this will not
scare them they won't be moving or won't
be leaving homes and that they will
continue to fight against these kind of
attacks and what do we know at this
point about who was behind these
attacks
well the police have at the moment
identified the two attackers they said
as coming from occupied West Bank they
also uh said that they had entered
illegally without work permits they said
that they both uh were known to the
security with security and criminal
records they said it's not clear as to
what uh were these uh security or
criminal threats that they're talking
about um but they are now investigating
ating they said to try and find out how
they managed to enter Israel without
these work permits they said that they
know for certain now that they work were
working at a car wash the owner of the
business is now uh being questioned uh
but yet the details are still uh being
uh revealed what we do know though is
that both apparently came from Hebron
one of them in their 40s this comes at a
time when there's been a huge debate uh
certainly on Saturday where the
government has prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has said that they will
consider now a plan to allow Palestinian
workers from the occupied West Bank to
enter Israel and work uh as long as they
are over the age of 45 just to give you
a little bit of a background this wasn't
on the radar a few uh weeks ago because
there's been a complete ban on
Palestinian workers from entering Israel
since that October 7th attack whether it
was from Gaza whether it's from the
occupied territories but what we do know
now is that they are considering this it
seems foreign workers uh trying to bring
them here has been a lot slower than
they expected but more importantly
there's been a lot of pressure not just
from the US but also from the head of
shinb that's the Israeli security agency
that has warned that if you don't allow
the workers back in not only is the
Israeli economy going to suffer but also
it will create a pressure cooker and
possibly a third intera in the occupied
West Bank all right for the moment
there in t
Aviv let's bring in nid ibraim now in Al
in the occupied West Bank soita
obviously as we've been saying details
on this still arriving right now uh
details still on the ground but as this
is filtering through to people in the
West Bank how is this going to impact
Palestinians living
there well I can dare to say very little
because yes the Israeli forces have have
started raiding the village of benim
where the perpetrators are believed to
be from they still have not gotten to
the houses of the perpetrators as the uh
raid is still in its early uh uh minutes
let's say but I can tell you that even
before the attack happened Israeli
forces have been waiting different areas
in habron which is near or at least the
governor where Ben is located you've
seen them in Dura killing one
Palestinian a 22y old as well as
injuring 10 Palestinians two of them in
critical conditions and at least one has
been announced as critically dead this
woman as believed by locals she was
standing on the top of uh her building
she was trying to film the uh Israeli
raid which she has been shot uh to the
Head also another man we've been seeing
videos of him Crawling After he has been
injured so all of this was not related
to the current attack and I'm standing
here in Al Al jalone refugee camp and
this is a place that is close to an
illegal Israeli settlement there are if
you can see uh those uh surveillance
cameras that are often used by the
Israeli forces and from this location in
particular two young Palestinian men
have been killed late on Sunday as they
were walking down the street now the
Israeli Army's radio says that they have
been trying to hurl a homemade
explosives at the Israeli soldiers but
really no one can tell you the
Palestinian narrative as you can see the
cameras are with the Israeli forces the
weapons and what have you so it can be
really confusing to those parents who
have so many questions and so little
answers all right nid ibraim lifers
there in the occupied West Bank
well AKA Eldar is a political analyst
and contributor to haret he joins us now
from Tel Aviv as well thanks very much
for being with us um so if I can ask you
first of all
um what you make of this attack um I
mean I I appreciate that details are
still thin on the ground at the moment
but it does appear that this that these
attacks were carried out by Palestinians
according uh to our reporting how should
we view the news of this in the context
of everything else that is happening
with Israel's war on Gaza and the uh
raids uh the frequent raids on
Palestinians in the West
Bank we should see this as a kind of a
message or wakeup call if you like to
the Israeli society that uh we are not
safe anywhere not in the North not in
the South when the uh war in Gaza is uh
still happening and uh in the northb is
attacking Israel and now we are not even
safe in the heart of Israel in the
center uh 10 minutes away from Tel Aviv
or from where uh I live that I'm
speaking to you from and uh the message
is that uh you cannot close the occupied
territories hermetically they will come
after you and uh if you don't like to
put an end to the conflict and find a a
settlement uh to the settlement's
problem um they will go after you and
there is no way to escape a political
settlement and uh uh just a week ago a
mayor of a city Caba near Rana where
this attack happened today was uh
suggesting to put uh um roadblocks at
the the enter at the entrance all the
entrances of the city so Israel is
becoming uh a kind of a uh a ghetto or a
series of ghettos that uh the message
from the Palestinians as long as we
don't feel safe at home in our cities
Israelis will not fa feel safe at their
home and we we heard this talk of a of a
kind of pressure cooker atmosphere uh
particularly in the occupied West Bank
right now with all of these ongoing
raids so is this something that in your
view was was
inevitable yeah and uh just uh yesterday
uh there was a report that the Israeli
Army the IDF decided to move combat
units from Gaza to the West Bank because
they uh have uh got the message that uh
the West Bank and Gaza are one unit and
when uh there is a war that is going on
in Gaza the West Bank cannot ignore it
cannot ignore the
fatalities uh and uh the they're the
same families they have relatives there
and uh it's like you know when Jews are
attacked in Paris um the Israeli Jews
care about it and they uh when when
South Africa is criticizing Israel their
are ministers who are suggesting to cut
the relationship with South Africa so
there is solidarity there is the
solidarity of Palestinians in the West
Bank with their brothers in in Gaza and
uh they also know that the Israeli
government is not willing to think about
the day after the war war and think
about the Palestinian State netan uh he
even didn't spell it out when the
president of the United States asked him
to talk about the two-state solution so
uh what happened today is a kind of a
suicide attack uh the perpetrator is
probably a young man who knew and I'm
not justifying it terror is Terror and
attacking an old woman that uh we just
uh we told that she died she passed away
is uh is something that is not done but
um when you have people that their life
is so miserable and there is no hope at
the end of the tunnel after 57 years of
occupation the Israeli people will have
to live with this kind of Daily News
appreciate your time AKA Elder thanks
very much for being with
us thank you